Ahuzudillahi mina shaytana rajim bismillahir rahmanir raheem Alhamdulillah iladhila yablughmidhatahul ka'ilun Wala yuhsin a'ma ahul aaddoon Wala yu addihakkahul mujtahidoon Alladhila yudiriku bardalhimam Wala yana aluhu khawsal fitan Alladhila isalisi fatihi haddun mahdudoon Wala na'atun majudoon Wala waqtun maadudoon Wala ajalun mamdudoon
Fataral khala ikabi qudratihi wa nasharar riyaha bir rahmatihi wa wattadabis suhuri maidana ardihi wa salatu wa salamu ala sayyid al ambiya'i wal mursaleen khatiman nabiyeen Sayyidin al-Mumadjad Bashir al-Musabdaq nadir al-Mu'ayyad al-Mustaf al-Amjad Mahmud al-Ahmad Abil Qasim Muhammad Wa salatu wa salamu ala wa siyihi ali ibn Abi Talib Aishraf al-wasiyeen wa amir al-Mumineen
Wa salatu wa salamu ala saydin alimamit tayyib sahibid dawatin nabawiyya wa saawlatul haydriyya wal Ismatul Fatimiyya wa shuja akul Husayniyya wa ulum albaqariyya wal maaqil al jaafariyya wal hikmatul Ismaailiyya wal judul Muhammadiyya fa salallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa salaymuhum tasliman kathiran kathira
Allahumma la ilmalana ila ma alamtana inna kaantal alimul hakeem Allahumma alimna bima yanfa'ana wa yanfa'ana bima alamtana Allahumma inna na'udu bikamin ail min la yanfaa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashbaa Allahumma inna na'udu bikamin daawatin la yusta jabulaha wa min mun karatil akhlaq wala amal wala hwa
Fa amma baadi akullu subhanahu wa ta'ala fi kitabi hil kareem, bada naqula auzubillahi mina shaytan regime.
Bismillah rahmanu raheem rabbish rahli sadri wa yasir li amdi.
Wahlul qdatam mill lisani yaf kahu kawli.
Allahum ma inni auzubikaan adalla aw udal, aw azillah aw uzal, aw aslim, aw uzlama alayya wa ajhal aw yujhal alayya
Allahum masabitna aimdal mautibila ilaha illallahu Allahum majalna minal lazeena amanu aamila salihat wa tawa saubil haqt wa tawa saubil sabr ameen ya rabil alameen once again assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu.
In the previous session we started this conversation about.
Rahma and you know I said that Rahma is generally weakly translated as mercy
But in reality, in Arabic linguistics, it is a much more powerful word.
And it basically is a combination of a few things.
We talked about it as a combination of four different things, four different emotions.
It's a combination of unconditional love.
It is a combination of constant care, genuine concern.
And then finally, it's mercy, it's compassion.
So we just generally think about Rahma as mercy, but then it is a much more complicated word.
And it has to be
geared towards the benefit for someone.
These four emotions, they don't, they do not necessarily translate as Rahma unless it actually results in benefiting somebody.
So as the Arab would say, Rahmatu rirkatun taqtali ehsanu ilal makhum.
So it is a love or it is a kind of tenderness that is specifically intended to benefit the beloved.
So that is what I explained the word Rahma means.
We looked at its two derivatives in the previous session, which is very commonly used.
These are Ar-Rahman and Ar-Rahim.
And we looked at the words that kind of follow the phonetic pattern of Ar-Rahman
in Arabic there is this is a certain linguistic pattern in which different words they kind of follow this rhyme so all words that.
Follow this phonetic pattern of Aan you know Rahman, Qadban, Hachan all of these they have three.
Things in common their intense they are immediate and it is temporary right so
The mercy of Al-Rahman is intense.
It is happening right now, but it is temporary only because a constant supply of that intense love would actually drive the human being insane.
And then there's a story of Hazrat Isa , I believe that.
So
I was saying that there was this story of Hazrat Isa that he was walking by a temple and he saw this old man who was in a state of meditation and he sensed that in his state of meditation he sensed that you know somebody extremely wholly pious is walking by he sensed the vibe he sensed that energy and he
broke his meditation and he said, you know, he asked who you are and Hazrat Isa explained that he is the Prophet of Allah and, you know, so Hazrat Isa asks this man that, this old man that why, you know, what are you doing in this wilderness sitting outside this temple and he says that Ya Ruhallah, you know, since 70 years I've been asking for one thing and one thing alone from Allah and I have not yet received it
and you are the prophet of me, you are the beloved prophet of Allah, so will you please intervene on my behalf and ask him to give me what I have been seeking?
And so Hazatisa asks him, you know, what is it that you are looking for?
What is it that you're seeking?
And he says, you know, Ya Isa , it's been 70 years asking for the love of Allah.
So what, you know, I want you to ask him on my behalf to grant me, you know,
a portion of that love so that I can experience that intense love of Allah.
Because I've heard about the Rahman and I have heard about how intense his love is and I want to experience it physically.
So can you ask him to give that to me.
So Hazateesa raises his hand in prayer and he asks Allah to fulfill the need of this old man and then he walks away because this temple was walking towards a certain destination and this temple happened to be on the way.
So he walks away and then when he returns on his way back, he goes back through the same path and he sees that, you know, where the temple has crumbled, it has completely been destroyed as like an earthquake had just taken place.
And there's this big hole, you know, in the ground and in there that man is standing there
with his eyes closed, just staring towards the sky in a state of complete, you know, shock.
And he's not responding to anything, he's not...
he cannot hear anything, he cannot say anything.
And so Hazrat Isa , he asks Allah, he says, What just happened here?
And, you know, I just asked you for, you know, for you to fulfill the need of this man, and now I see him in this completely
shocked state.
So what just happened here?
So Allah responds to Hazratis and he says, Ya Ruhallah, you know, you asked me for something that this man was not, no human being is capable of withstanding.
And he said that you asked me to give, grant him my love.
And I gave him, you know, from the intensity of my love, I reduced it down to 70,000.
So I gave him one portion from 70,000 portions of my love, of my Rahmaniya, I made him experience that and look what has happened to him.
Now you tell me if I had given him a little bit more, what if one portion from that 70,000
levels of my Rahmaniya has brought him down to this condition.
You just imagine what would have happened to him if I gave him some more.
So even the Rahmaniya that we experience, the intensity of his love that we experience in this world is just a minute fraction, not even one of that level, because just one level of that intense love can drive an extremely pious man.
This is not, we're not talking about any average human being, right?
This is a person who spent
70 years of his life in meditation.
So you can imagine the level of piety and he could not withstand one percent of that, not one percent, one fraction of that love.
So, you know, for us human beings, you know, we don't, we probably, you know, what we experience is not even that much and yet, you know, there are people, there are so many stories in which people go insane.
So Ar-Rahman is basically intense love, it's immediate love and because of that intensity, it is temporary.
and then we looked at the word Ar-Rahim which is a long-term permanent kind of love and the reason Ar-Rahman and Ar-Rahim are used in combination is to cover all these different aspects because if a love is immediate
And it's, you know, if it was just a Rahman, it would be intense, it would be immediate, but then it would be temporary.
So a Rahman takes, is used, is there, or the Rahmaniya of Allah is there to take care of the immediate concerns of the human being, whereas a Rahim is there to take care of his long-term concerns and long-term care and unconditional love and mercy.
So that is where we and I said that all words that fall on this pattern of this pattern of Rahim also has the same qualities and many of the names of Allah actually fall on this pattern.
So we know most of them, right?
Kareem and Jaleel and Jamil and all of that.
So they're all they all have these same and between this intensity and
you know immediate attention versus you know permanent and long-term attention Allah has covered basically all grounds and a human being is basically all not just human being but all of creation is basically wrapped up and engulfed in this constant supply of love in one form or the other.
So that is what we talked about in the previous session.
In today's session
what I want I want to continue this conversation further and I want to actually we looked at the two derivatives of Rahma right which was Rahman and Rahim today I actually want to talk about where the word Rahma itself comes from so just keep the definition of Rahma in mind which is the combination of those four things unconditional love constant care genuine and sincere concern and unconditional mercy right so
there is...
keep the definition of Rahma, you know, before you, so that you can properly understand where...
when I explain the origin, the root of this word, it will help you really appreciate the kind of love we're talking about.
And also that, you know, it is obviously for the benefit
It is always targeted towards the benefit of someone otherwise it's not Rahma.
So today we'll look at the root word for Rahma which actually comes from the word Rahm.
Okay, the word Rahma it comes from the word Rahm and the word Rahm in Arabic it actually means the womb of a mother when she's carrying a child.
Raham is the place where the baby lives inside the mother where the fetus develops for nine months before the child is born in this world.
Now, why do you think Allah chose a word for mercy that derives from the womb of a mother?
Because the womb of a mother, it actually describes the relationship between Allah and His creation.
And this is what makes it so beautiful.
Now, what I find interesting that, you know, both parents love their children, right?
You know, father and mother all love the child.
But what I find interesting is that in the Quran, whenever Allah compares His mercy for His creation, He never uses the example of a father.
Never.
He always uses the example of a mother.
So in order to truly understand and appreciate the meaning of the word Rahma, right?
In order to truly understand and appreciate the kind of relationship Allah has with us, we must first understand the relationship of a mother with her child, when she's carrying that child in her womb.
There is a famous hadith in which Allah is actually speaking directly to the womb.
Rasulullah tells us that there's this hadith in which Allah actually talks to the womb.
And obviously, you know, the womb here means the archetypal womb because the womb of a mother is how all of humanity exists in the world today.
Right?
We all came as a result of the womb of our mothers.
And so, Allah spoke directly to this womb and He said, I named you from one of my names.
In other words, I am a Rahman, I am a Raheem, and so I am deriving the name of my unconditional love, my constant care, my genuine concern, and my infinite mercy, right?
I am naming my Rahma based on
your womb your Raham so I am giving you one of my names I am a Rahman I am a Rahim I have Rahma and that is why I am calling you the womb Raham I'm making you a symbol of my Rahma and my unconditional love because every single human being that will exist through time will exist because of you they will come in this world through you
and you will remind them of my love for them Your Rahman Rahman is the very first thing womb is the very first thing that they will experience before they come in this world and my Rahma is what they will experience once they are born in this world until the day they return to me that is the conversation that Rahman had with the womb
which is the Raham, right?
I have named you from one of My names.
Now, what is it about the womb of a mother that is important for us to understand?
Well, there are a few things.
The very first question that I want to place before you is that when a child is inside the womb of its mother, is it being punished?
Is there any association with the concept of punishment for the baby when it is inside the womb of its mother?
Remember, we talked about this in the previous session, that generally mercy is related to punishment, that there was some kind of punishment that was going to happen and then the person decides not to go ahead with that punishment, right?
So if we are now comparing, if we're trying to understand the word rahmah through the womb of a mother, let's put these questions to actually answer some of these
or rather strengthen some of these concepts.
That a child in the womb of a mother, there is no concept of punishment there.
Right?
Absolutely not.
What's the relationship of the mother with the baby when it's in the womb?
It's pure love.
Right?
And what is that a reminder for?
It is a reminder of the very kind of relationship that Allah has with His creation.
That it is based on pure love.
It has nothing to do with punishment.
The moment a woman finds out that she is pregnant, she falls in love with that baby.
It doesn't matter, even if she never planned on having child, never planned on having children, every woman, the second she becomes pregnant, the first emotion she feels for the baby is love.
She hasn't even seen the baby yet, has she?
She hasn't met the baby yet.
but she still falls completely and unconditionally in love with her baby the moment she finds out she's pregnant.
So that's the first thing that I want to put forth when we discuss this word mercy that it has nothing to do with punishment.
It has everything to do with love.
And secondly, did the womb exist before the mother conceived?
Or does the body just create the womb when she gets pregnant and then discards it later?
It doesn't, right?
The womb exists within every woman, baby or no baby, the womb is always there, right?
Similarly, Allah's Rahma, His unconditional love, His care, His concern, His mercy, it's always there.
His Rahma does not exist because we exist or because humanity exists or you know because creation exists No! His Rahma is always there and will always remain there even when we no longer exist even when all of humanity no longer exists even when this universe no longer exists just as the womb exists even after the child is born you understand?
I'm drawing that parallel over there
so just by examining the womb we get answers to some really interesting questions you know it really helps us understand some of these you know it's SubhanAllah the way Allah has designed everything is just incredible that you know it gives us so many lessons just by examining how certain things work and how he has named them after some of his own emotions and principles now when the child is inside the womb of its mother
Does the child even know that it is being taken care of?
Does it even know that the mother exists?
It doesn't.
Right?
So it is being taken care of in ways that it cannot even imagine.
I mean, forget realizations and appreciations.
I mean, that comes all later.
The fetus in the womb of its mother cannot even imagine what role the womb is playing in its life to maintain its existence.
In the same way, Allah is taking care of us in ways that we cannot even possibly imagine or realize.
He is taking care of us in such a subtle manner that, you know, we forget His Rahma.
even his presence becomes invisible to us you know he's taking care of us in such a subtle manner that is why one of his name is Latif right the word Latif that comes from Lutf it means something that is extremely subtle something that is there that is constantly working behind the scenes for you but you don't feel its presence that's Latif
Allah is constantly there, He's constantly working 24/7, never takes a break, never sleeps, never gets tired all of that is in place and we forget His existence because He's working in such a subtle manner behind the scenes but what's amazing isn't that in the Quran every time the attribute Latif is used, what other attribute comes with it?
Always Khabir, the All-Knowing, you see?
your eyes cannot see him but he is aware of what your eyes are seeing your eyes cannot see him but he is aware of what your eyes are seeing he is extremely subtle but at the same time he's also all-knowing right so you forget
You become unaware of His presence but He knows everything.
SubhanAllah.
So the child doesn't even know that the mother is taking care of it just as we don't even realize how Allah is taking care of us.
The next thing that comes to mind when you think of the womb is protection.
The mother is constantly protecting the baby.
Right?
Have you ever seen a pregnant woman walk?
I mean, she watches the corners of the table when she walks, right?
She always tries to be safe.
She sleeps on her side, right?
She watches what she eats.
She's constantly caressing her tummy, the baby, right?
She loves the baby.
She cares for the baby.
And that's why she's extremely protective of it.
This is exactly what Allah is doing for us constantly.
I mean you kids you know you guys you don't just make it to school just like that I mean can you even imagine how many things can go wrong the horror stories that we hear I mean in just the time you leave the house to the time you enter your school there are millions of things that can go wrong I'm not even talking you know back from school
the duration of the school and the time that you return home I'm not even talking about that just the time between you leave and you reach school million things can go wrong but Allah is protecting them He's protecting all of us He's keeping us safe same for us when we leave for work or whatever right every single day people walk out of their homes and but not everyone returns that night do these people who die in car crashes or accidents
Did they know that they're not going to return home tonight?
When the time comes, that's it, right?
But until that time comes, what is constantly protecting them from accidents and all kinds of harm?
Allah's Rahma.
So just as the womb is constantly protecting its creation, Allah is constantly protecting His own creation.
That is what the womb of a mother is reminding us.
then so I hope this is helping you draw understand that the whole idea of this conversation is to take these concepts of a mother and the and the baby in her womb and apply it to Allah with us so it's that microcosm macrocosm thing that that's going on here right it's a perfect parallel so then if we look at this relationship further
This mother puts up a lot of difficulties, you know, she puts up with a lot of difficulties for her baby, doesn't she?
A mother deals with constant morning sickness.
Some have to go through horribly painful tests, you know, get all of these injections and God knows what, right?
Some have to take extremely nauseating medicines for the health and growth of the baby.
They have to get blood work done constantly.
It's one painful thing after another.
A mother goes through, you know, all these stages when the baby is developing and in that process she goes through a lot of pain and for the sake of what?
Her child.
Which again, by the way, the child is completely unaware of.
The child takes the mother completely for granted, just as we take the Rahmah of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for granted.
And technically, if you think about it, the child in the womb of its mother is doing nothing for the mother, and yet the mother is doing everything for the child.
The baby eats her food, right?
The poor woman just, you know, ate.
and within minutes that damn baby takes up everything and she's like you know seriously stop it right she just ate this huge meal and minutes later she's hungry again and then the husband has to run in the middle of the night for ice cream because the baby is taking everything from her and it's not giving anything back to her in return
And when he does actually thank her, when the baby does that, what does it do?
It kicks the mother from the inside.
I mean, that's like, thank you.
You know, it just decides to stretch from time to time inside.
It decides to do this in the middle of the night, it decides to do this insanity workout just whenever it feels like it.
But every time the child does something, who goes through pain?
The mother.
She silently but happily endures it.
Now that is incredible.
Think about that for a second.
That is incredible.
The mother is in a constant state of discomfort because of this baby and yet she is happily enduring it.
We are doing absolutely nothing for Allah.
Allah is doing absolutely everything for us.
right I mean with Allah it's so weird because we cannot do anything for Him even if we wanted to even as mature adults even after after understanding this Rahma what is it that we can do for Him we cannot add anything to His kingdom we cannot take anything away from His kingdom our good deeds do not benefit Him our bad deeds do not harm Him
we cannot make him any any more wealthier than he is any more richer than he is we cannot make him poor you know we cannot praise him in any way or any more than he has already praised everything in the heavens and the earth is in constant praise for him right so what are we going to do we cannot do anything for him I mean just just take a moment
to appreciate that there is absolutely nothing that we can offer Allah and yet He is constantly doing things for us without us even realizing His presence and in many cases even without acknowledging His presence right He is constantly working for us every moment He's busy in work
He's constantly keeping this universe and everything within this universe functional.
How many blessings of Allah can you possibly deny?
Subhanallah.
I hope we can you're appreciating that mercy that concept of mercy of Allah that nobody you know tell me one person you know who's gonna do that you constantly do for somebody in your life who does absolutely nothing for you how long is that relationship gonna last no matter who you are I don't care if you're Mother Teresa right just
Doesn't work that way.
But look at when we look at our relationship with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, it's like, whoa.
So then the womb, it reminds us that all the needs of the child are being met by its mother.
The child is completely surrounded, right?
But it's completely enveloped by the love and the care of its mother.
That's the idea of the womb, right?
It's a circle, it's like a ball, it's like a bubble.
So he's completely engulfed in that mercy, in that Raham.
His food, his drinks, all of that is taken care of.
Even when the child excretes, all of that is taken care by the body of the mother.
Everything that that child needs is completely provided for.
Right?
The rent is paid, housing and boarding is free, does not have to pay for the utilities.
All meals are included.
In other words, the baby is completely wrapped up in the love and the care of its mother, right?
In the same way, we are completely wrapped up in the unconditional love, the care, the concern and the mercy of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He provides us with our sustenance.
He gives us the luxuries of a good life.
He makes the outside world functional for us.
He's keeping the inside world functional for us, right?
My heart is beating.
My organs, they're working.
My breath is coming in and out.
I can walk.
I can speak.
And He's making all of this happen for me.
He gave me parents.
He gave me teachers.
He gave me knowledge.
He gave me my own family.
So He surrounded me with all comforts of my life.
You know how we complain about paying the bills?
You know, like our mortgage and utility expenses and school fees and things like that?
I mean, just think for a second, how much do we pay for our sight?
How much do we pay Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for our ability to hear, our abilities to speak?
our ability to breathe forget everything else how much are we paying for each and every breath that we take let me ask you a different question how much would you pay for your breath right now if if just right now if you couldn't breathe and Allah asked you to pay for the next breath what would you be willing to pay for that next breath what would that breath be worth to you
Can you just appreciate how we take things for granted?
I mean when you ask these questions it really puts things in perspective for us right?
So then what do we pay for our hands for our ability to walk?
I mean we are going through life that is a life that is immensely blessed with uncountable bounties.
we are immensely blessed with the riches and provisions he created for us all of which we take completely for granted right and he is okay with that he still continues to serve us just like the mother keeps serving the baby what is if the if the mother stops doing what she's doing in the for the baby in its womb what is the baby capable of doing can he say oh fine if you're not going to do it for me I'll do it myself can the baby say that
How helpless is that baby inside the womb of its mother for its sustenance and its development, for its continued existence?
Completely.
So are we.
Do we realize that?
Do we appreciate that?
Are we grateful for that?
And so far, you know, we've only talked about the benefits of the child.
Let's talk about the motivation for this mother.
So I said the baby is not, you know, doing anything for the mother.
It's not paying the mother in any way.
It's not giving anything back to the mother.
So then what is the motivation for this mother to carry on?
Despite all the discomfort this child is putting her through, what could be possibly motivating this mother to carry on doing what she's doing?
If you think about that question, if you really reflect on that question, the only motivation you'll see that the mother has for the baby is that of an extreme form of unconditional love.
That is how Allah looks at us.
As the child grows in the womb of its mother, it becomes more and more of a problem for the mother.
Right?
From a physical standpoint.
As time passes and the embryo grows in size, it becomes more and more of a problem for its mother.
But what happens to her love?
She falls more and more in love with her baby.
She constantly increases in her love.
Now that is incredible.
And we know that when that baby comes out of her, we know that it almost kills her.
She goes through this immense pain of childbirth, which obviously men we cannot understand.
Right?
But we see it.
I mean if nine months of torture wasn't enough, this baby causes this incredibly intense pain at childbirth.
and the emotions are incredible you know I've been in the delivery room twice so I have seen what that pain is like you know when Nazeen was in labor she was in labor I think for eight hours at the time of hero and I'm sure there are mothers in the group that have gone through much worse you know but personally I've you know at least in my life I've never seen anyone go through so much pain for that extended period of time but
And I remember when Edam came out, you know, the doctor tried to hand her to me, right?
All excited and just like that, just directly.
And she was covered up in all of this gooey stuff.
And I was like, you, you know, what is this?
Can you please clean this thing first?
Right?
So that was my emotion.
But I remember when they brought Edam to Nazleen,
Right?
So with this incredible love, she touched her cheeks, I remember, and she said, Hi, baby.
And then she passed up.
I mean, that was an insane moment, at least in my life.
And I'm never going to forget that.
And I still don't get it.
And probably never will.
I mean, I thought she would hate this baby who caused her so much pain.
I thought she would scream at her, yell at her.
curse her out.
You almost killed me.
I hate you.
I never want to touch you again.
That's not what happened.
Instead, the very first time they brought Adam to her, she gave her a big hug and kissed her.
I've never seen anyone in so much pain and this happy at the same time.
SubhanAllah.
Anyone else who causes so much pain to you
Anyone who makes you bleed this way, that a child makes the mother bleed at childbirth, you would not give them a hug.
I promise you, you would not give them a hug.
We made our mothers bleed almost to death in certain cases and as soon as we come out of her womb, she showers us with love.
And that love increases for us.
after going through that process.
She falls more in love with our mothers fell more in love with us than they ever did before.
And this is seconds after we tried to kill her.
So you tell me what kind of relationship is that?
It's a completely illogical relationship.
This is not a relationship you and I can make any sense of.
It's beyond our logic because this does not happen with any other relationship.
There is no other relationship in your life or my life that works this way.
You know, where you just never give, you never give, you only receive, you only take and still all you get back in return is love, more love.
You keep demanding and she keeps giving, right?
you know how certain people in life they just feel like oh I'm a terrible person why would Allah ever love me and why would he care for me and he's never gonna forgive me I'm doomed that's it right it's the end of the road I've done so many bad things now forget it I'm never gonna ever be worthy of his mercy that just doesn't make logical sense you know why I would never forgive anybody like me so you know why would Allah forgive me well ask the baby who just tried to kill the mother in childbirth
how does the mother feel for that baby and you'll have your answer you know we cannot even humanize Allah's love like forget you know you reduce Allah's love and Allah says that I love you 70,000 times more than a mother loves the child now imagine that we cannot even understand the love of a mother for the child or really appreciate it how are we gonna you know why how dare you
blame Allah in that way that He's not going to forgive you.
How dare you?
After what a child does to her mother when she comes out of the womb, look at how the mother treats that child.
And if a mother can do that, you think Allah cannot do that?
Subhanallah.
and by the way your mother bled so much to give you life she just went through childbirth or surgery to give you life and what happens right after you are born what does she have to do now she has to feed you and feeding
as we know is also a very painful thing for some women.
Anyone else in this world, anyone right who goes through surgery or goes through any kind of intense pain they say I need six weeks off, I need two months off, I need a break, I need a vacation.
Does a mother get a two-month break after she gives birth to you?
No.
You break a leg and you get six months off from school.
She just almost died giving birth to you and she's on the clock right away.
The moment you are born, she is working full time after going through that childbirth.
And what do babies give back to the mother in return?
I mean, she gives the baby milk.
She gives it life.
She gives it love.
She gives it care.
She's constantly concerned about it.
She's constantly protecting it.
She bathes it, oils it, changes diapers like every five minutes.
And she does all of this through countless sleepless nights, month after month, year after year.
What does the baby do in return?
Does the baby say thank you?
Does it show gratitude?
Does it sing praises for the mother?
No.
Does the mother still keep loving and caring her baby over and over again?
Yes, she does.
The only reward the baby offers is what?
By urinating on her?
Pooping on her?
Throwing up on her?
And even when the baby does that, how does the mother respond?
Toss it out of the window?
No, she actually finds that cute.
Oh, so cute.
And then she cleans the baby up.
Oh, it's okay my little baby.
Don't worry here.
you know I've changed you now you're gonna feel all better I mean that's the conversation I've seen moms have with the child after they just urinated and pooped on them isn't that an incredibly beautiful relationship?
but at the same time isn't it also an extremely insane relationship?
but this is what Allah is doing for us this is what
Allah is doing for us on a much more larger scale and that also doesn't make sense because it's you know Allah's love for us doesn't make sense it's beyond logical reasoning we just cannot limit Allah's love to common sense because yes we do not deserve this kind of love from Him that is what common sense would tell you
If all of us, we honestly judge our actions, you know, if we look at our ingratitude towards Allah, you know, there's absolutely no reason for Allah to continue taking care of us.
I mean, we...
We don't even take the time out to remember Him five times in a day.
That's...
What is that, two hours?
If you do all the namaz, fars nafal, what is that, two hours out of 16 hours?
And that's all it takes, right?
We'll watch a three-hour Indian movie, see this idiot chase this girl around a tree.
We'll do that.
We'll watch a five-hour soccer match.
We'll watch an all-day cricket match, right?
Rewind and play over and over again.
Look at that shot.
Look how amazing, right?
Yeah, it's okay.
It's only been four hours.
So what?
You know, it's okay.
We have time for all of those trivial activities, but we will not take out two hours for our creator.
Not even two hours, 30 minutes, just a five.
We don't even do that much to just say thank you.
We constantly disobey Him after everything He does for us.
We do everything He tells us not to do.
And some of us, we don't even acknowledge His existence.
I mean, who knows if there's an Allah or not, and who cares if there is?
And yet He keeps giving us, He keeps feeding us, He keeps providing for us, He keeps forgiving us.
It's something truly incredible.
And I'm mostly just thinking of myself right now.
I mean, despite my constant ingratitude, my constant disloyalty, you know, my constant defiance to His every command, I am still waking up every morning.
I am still breathing oxygen.
I am still going about my day, you know, eating and drinking all this delicious food that He provides for me.
I'm still enjoying life to the fullest.
He takes none of that away from me.
And yes, that doesn't make sense.
It just doesn't make sense.
But that is Allah's Rahma.
And, you know, just
And you know, you want to see how ungrateful human beings are?
Just look at what we do with food.
Look at the amount of food that we waste.
His greatest blessing for mankind, the very means of sustenance.
Look how we disrespect that food.
I mean, have you ever studied the etiquettes of eating in that Chahal Sabaq?
The Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam, he said, sit before your food
like a slave sits before its master.
Cover your head before you eat out of respect for that food.
Do not place your plate on the floor elevated from the ground in order to honor it.
When you're done eating find those grains and those crumbs that have fallen off your plate and put them in your mouth.
Suck the food off your fingers
That's the kind of respect and honor we should have for food in our lives.
Why?
One, because without it, we cannot even imagine what our lives would be reduced to.
And second, just think about the amount of effort it took behind the scenes to get that food on your plate.
I mean, can you appreciate the time, the effort
the protection, the management, the planning that goes into taking a seed, growing it into a plant, having the animal eat it, taking care of the animal, feeding it, protecting it until it reaches the proper age, getting that animal into the hands of the one who is going to do zabihah in order to make it halal for us, getting that dead animal
or that food into the supermarket or the meat shop so that you end up buying it, giving you the provisions to buy it, providing you with the tools to cook it until that food finally makes it to your plate.
That is years and years and years of Allah's labor that sits before you in your plates.
But do we care?
No, we take a few bites and toss it away.
It wasn't warm enough, wasn't fresh enough, not enough salt, right?
Kids, you guys do projects for school, right?
Imagine you worked on a school project for months and months and the second you present it to your teacher, he just tosses it out of the window or steps on it or breaks it or whatever.
How would you feel?
and then that professor tells you okay for next month I want you to work on this project you tell me how you will respond will you go through that effort again?
look what we do with Allah's effort and look what He does.
Does He stop that food from us?
right?
some people say why can't we waste food we can afford it well
You should not waste food out of respect.
It doesn't matter how rich you are, how much money you have, how much food you can buy.
It's not about that.
It's not about the quantity.
It's about looking at the effort behind everything that took place to get that food to you.
It is about respecting that Rahma, that love of the Creator.
Why do you think Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wa sallam placed all these etiquettes in Sharia?
If you read Daim al-Islam or you know Chahal Sabaq and all these rules, what do you think those rules are there to remind you of?
All rules of Sharia are a constant reminder for us because we are insan, right?
We are forgetful creatures.
We constantly, you know, need reminders because we are insan.
So
Somebody who constantly forgets, he needs constant reminders.
Reminders of what?
Allah's mercy.
His Rahma.
All of Sharia is basically just a reminder of that.
Reminder of Allah's mercy.
Because as soon as any decent human being is presented and reminded of the love, care, concern and mercy of another person,
His natural response is praise and gratitude.
That's his natural response.
If that person is a decent human being.
If it's not a decent human being, then it's just similar to an animal.
You feed an animal.
Even an animal actually is grateful.
That is what makes us so terrible because you put a food in front of an animal.
Have you ever seen a thirsty dog?
If you ever have a thirsty dog and you put a bowl of water in front of it, after it has taken its drink, it's going to look up to you and you will see that gratitude in its size.
Even an animal in many cases is better than human being.
But we unfortunately are ungrateful people.
We continuously disrespect and disregard Allah's efforts and He constantly keeps providing for us.
He gives us food, He gives us shelter, He clothes us one better than the next.
Just like the mother keeps feeding her baby regardless of what it does.
Does the baby care about the months and months of intense effort that went into letting it grow from a drop of liquid into this fully developed child, then from a child to an adult?
No.
Does the mother stop loving the child ever?
No, because this is insane love.
There is absolutely no rhyme or reason for Allah to love us this way but He does He still does always will Why?
Because He has Rahma for us Because this is the kind of relationship He has with us of unconditional love constant care, genuine concern and constant mercy constant mercy What happens to the womb as the baby grows in size?
It expands.
SubhanAllah, it expands to accommodate the baby.
It expands to accommodate the need of the baby.
Allah's love, His mercy, His compassion, His forgiveness, it constantly expands to accommodate the needs of His creation.
This is the love of our Creator for us.
This is Rahmah.
If you want to understand Rahma, understand and appreciate the womb of a mother.
Oh womb, I have named you after my names.
I have named you Raham to remind you that I am Rahman and I am Rahim.
I have made you a symbol of my love so that every human being recognizes and appreciates my unconditional love for them.
through you and by your example.
Because none of us, no creation in this world is going to come in this world without that Raham.
Nobody can miss it, you see.
Do you see the beauty of this design?
And just as we will never be able to understand the love of a mother for her child, we will never be able to understand
and appreciate the love and care of Allah for his creation but if we are if there's any semblance of decency in us the least the very least we can do is acknowledge it and be grateful for it right so
That's the understanding of the word Raham and Rahma, that He gave us mothers so that we can taste one drop of that endless ocean of love that Allah has for His creation.
So, you know, while you are, after the session, while you guys are hugging your mothers, don't forget to be appreciative
of the one who gave you that mother and who loves you the same way more than your mother will ever love you and be grateful to him and the best way to be grateful and express that gratitude to Allah is to leave whatever you're doing when he calls you in the form of those five prayers to show that we are all decent human beings we are not ungrateful people right to show him that my
you know my to show that sleep is not as important to me as Allah is you know my work is not as important my homework my schoolwork is not as important to me as Allah is you know my you know my my my own tiredness is not as important that is I'm never going to be tired enough to not be grateful to Allah because he never gets tired giving me anything
He never stops working from me, not providing my food because he was tired.
And he is constantly working 24/7.
I don't have to work that.
He gives me eight hours of good sleep.
So the least I can do to show him that, express that gratitude to him is to complete my five days of, you know, my five times namaz every day.
That's the least I could do for him, that I could just drop whatever I'm doing, break any idol that I am worshipping, and just stand before him and fall in sajdah before him to say, Thank you.
...............................
Al-Fateha.